it was a picture taken of you at a
fashion show years ago years ago at a
Burberry fashion show and apparently it
was they just caught you at a moment you
were making a face for no apparent
reason there you are I I mean I do I
look so so confused by fashion but I
don't know why I was making that face
yeah and that can happen sometimes they
can get a picture of you in this one
moment where you're just probably
looking off and squinting right
you smell someone cooking hot peppers
and they capture that moment
well now it's become this thing it's
everywhere on the Internet and you've
been experienced this before where
people just love to in waves it comes in
yes they put you reacting to different
things yeah and it has just made such a
resurgence this is so so interesting
yeah like for example we found this one
of you reacting to a model with Gus
Frings face I think I know him he looks
somewhat familiar I remember I have bad
associations with him there was this one
with Forrest Gump that I really liked
and I loved it someone put you this
works so well this one where they put
you the Trump inaugural what do you guys
so you're just those things research and
there seems to be no reason where I'm a
reason for it yeah go away for a while
and then and then there's the reddit had
this kind of mean competition I don't
know yeah and so people just started
making photos again yeah
you